>> Tucker: BIG TECH
COMPANIES TRY TO CONTROL WHAT
YOU SEE ONLINE, OF COURSE.
BUT THEY ALSO TRY TO CONTROL
WHAT YOU DON'T SEE.
A NEW REPORT, SHOCKING ONE
FROM BREITBART EXPOSES
EXISTENCE OF A GOOGLE
BLACKLIST FOR, "CONTROVERSIAL
YouTube QUERIES."
QUESTIONS THAT YOU ASK ON
YouTube.
TRYING TO FIND VIDEOS.
THE FLAGRANT ABUSE NOT
SURPRISINGLY CONCERNS
ABORTION.
AFTER RECEIVING A COMPLAINT
FROM A POLITICAL ACTIVIST
POSING AS A ALL RIGHT ROER AT
SLATE.com -- A LOT OF
THOSE -- THEY DECIDED TO BURY
THE VIDEOS AND REPLACE THEM
WITH THE PRO-ABORTION VIDEOS.
FOR EXAMPLE, BY ANTHONY
LETEVUNO WERE BURIED AND DE
PLACED BY THE PRO-ABORTION
CONTENT FROM BUZZ FEED AND
CNN.
IN A STATEMENT, THEY DENIED
DOING ANYTHING WRONG AND SAID
ANY SHIFT WAS DUE TO
ALGORITHMS, WHICH ARE OF
COURSE CONTROLLED BY PEOPLE.
WE ARE JOINED BY THE
PSYCHOLOGIST AT THE BEHAVIORAL
INSTITUTE AND TECHNOLOGY.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
YOU WERE THE FIRST PERSON I
THOUGHT OF WHEN I READ THE
STORY BECAUSE YOU HAVE DONE I
THINK THE CUTTING EDGE
RESEARCH IN THE EFFECT OF
SEARCH, GOOGLE SEARCH, AND
OTHER DIGITAL PLATFORMS ON
HUMAN BEHAVIOR.
POLITICAL BEHAVIOR.
WHAT KIND OF EFFECT COULD THIS
SORT OF DISTORTION HAVE ON AN
ELECTION?
>> YOU KNOW I'M NOT A
CONSERVATIVE.
>> I DO.
>> I LOVE AMERICA.
I LOVE DEMOCRACY.
I THINK WE SHOULD ALL BE
RISING ABOVE THE POLITICS
HERE.
AND RECOGNIZE THE EXTREME
DANGER THAT WE ARE FACING WHEN
A COMPANY LIKE GOOGLE CAN
BASICALLY SENSOR ANYTHING IT
WANTS TO SEN -- CENSURE
ANYTHING THEY WANT TO CENSURE.
THIS IS A LEAK THAT CONFIRMS
WHAT WE HAVE BEEN SAYING AND
WRITING FOR YEARS.
IT CONFIRMS NUMBER ONE THAT
INDIVIDUAL EMPLOYEES AT GOOGLE
HAVE THE POWER TO MANUALLY
REMOVE MATERIAL REMAUVE THE
CONTENT WE SEE.
THEY DO WITH POLITICAL ENDS.
NUMBER TWO, THIS TELLS US THAT
THE GOOGLE C.E.O. COMMITTED
PERJURY WHEN HE TESTIFIED
BEFORE CONGRESS A FEW WEEKS
AGO.
HE SAID QUITE SPECIFICALLY
THAT GOOGLE NEVER DOES THIS.
>> SO I MEAN MY FRUSTRATION
LEVELS ARE SO HIGH I DON'T
WANT TO TAKE IT OUT ON YOU.
BUT THE FIRST THOUGHT WHY
ISN'T HE BEING RECALLED BACK
TO CONGRESS TO EXPLAIN HIMSELF
OR FACE CHARGES?
YOU ARE NOT ALLOWED TO COMMIT
PERJURY.
MY QUESTION IS CAN ANY OF US
TRUST THAT THE NEXT ELECTION
WON'T BE SWAYED DRAMATICALLY
IN ONE DIRECTION BY
INTERFERENCE FROM THE TECH
COMPANIES?
>> I GUARANTEE YOU THAT THIS
PAST ELECTION WAS AFFECTED.
I'LL BE RELEASING SOME DATA ON
THIS I HOPE IN EARLY MARCH.
I PUBLISHED A PIECE IN WHICH I
SHOWED THAT JUST ONE
MANIPULATION ON GOOGLE'S PART
ON ELECTION DAY, THE GO VOTE
REMINDER.
THAT ONE REMINDER, THAT GO
VOTE REMINDER SHIFTED BETWEEN
800,000 AND 4.6 MILLION VOTES
TO DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATES ON
ELECTION DAY IN 2018.
>> SO WHY ISN'T THIS THE
HACKING OF OUR DEMOCRACY?
HOW CAN YOU HAVE A DEMOCRACY
UNDER THE CIRCUMSTANCES?
>> WELL, DEMOCRACY IS AN
ILLUSION AT THIS POINT.
WE HAVE LET THE COMPANIES,
GOOGLE MORE THAN ANY OTHER GO
COMPLETELY WILD.
THERE ARE NO RULES, NO
REGULATIONS, NO LAWS THAT
RESTRICT ANYTHING THEY DO.
AGAIN, THE MORE ONE LOOKS AT
WHAT IT IS THEY ARE ACTUALLY
DOING.
THE NEW LEAKS HELP A LOT IN MY
OPINION.
CLOSER ONE LOOKS AT WHAT THEY
ARE DOING, THE MORE OUTRAGED
ONE SHOULD BECOME.
I WANT TO EMFA SAYS WE
SHOULD -- EMPHASIZE, WE SHOULD
ALL BE OUTRAGED.
NOT JUST CONSERVATIVES.
>> I AGREE.
I HOPE THAT WHAT YOU JUST SAID